bonjour nicolas bonjour ravi de vous
retrouver dans cette matinale d'ayrté
france alors les 20 et 28 octobre
dernier un groupe d'eurodéputés a tenu
pas moins de deux conférences de presse
passé plutôt inaperçu d'ailleurs dans
les autres médias de quoi s'agit-il et
ben oui c'était les 20 et 28 octobre
dernier qu'un groupe d'eurodéputés
organisé magritte deux conférences de
presse dans la salle de presse du
parlement européen à bruxelles devant
une poignée de journalistes alors les
autres devaient être au g20 à rome
devant inscrits puis à la cop16 à
glasgow devant une bière pour assister
un vaudeville de chefs d'état du monde
entier qui l'on joue écolo malgré des
traités de libre échange et kostine
plein les poches quand l'a redit qu'il
ne tue pas la température monte chers
amis enfin bon mais revenons à ces
eurodéputés qui ne sont pas venues ces
20 et 28 octobre dernier pour donner
leur avis sur la taille des tomates
espagnoles sur le diamètre de la
mozzarella italienne ou sur la
circonférence des pommes de terre
néerlandaise non cécile eurodéputés ont
tenu deux conférences de presse explosif
sur la politique sanitaire et vaccinal
de l'union européenne dans lesquelles
ils ont notamment dénoncé écoutez bien
la répression de certains états membres
envers leurs populations qui manifestent
entre les mesures sanitaires un peu
partout en europe il a été aussi
question des contrats signés entre
l'union européenne les labos
pharmaceutiques dont certaines parties
ont été biffés en noir là le monde
christine anderson l'italienne francesca
de nato le croate ivan billy burke et
nietzsche ou encore le roumain cristian
de thérèse sont venus courageusement
face caméra pour dénoncer l'obligation
vaccinale et l'oppression des peuples
pour qu'ils adhèrent de façon contrainte
et les yeux fermés aux injonctions
gouvernementales
ces conférences de presse pour peu qu'on
prenne le temps mais écoutez bien
entendu pose des questions fondamentales
sur l'avenir de nos démocraties
européennes sur la notion même de
citoyens sur la force des raisonnables
auxquelles certains états en recours
pour maintenir un ordre sanitaire établi
et enfin sur le postulat que les états
dits démocratiques ne cherche pas
forcément le bien des populations alors
ce matin chers amis ne sera pas question
ni thomas nides passe technique pour
jacques certifié aux règles bruxelloise
mais du rapport ambigu que l'union
européenne entretient avec la démocratie
est ce qu'en disent les médias
mainstream ici en france magali un an
nicolas vous vous étonnez que cette
conférence de presse soit passée
totalement inaperçue en france mais
selon vous cela aurait mérité un
éclairage ben oui car ses conférences de
presse ont été passées dans la grosse
machine du motus et bouche cousue des
médias meanstream français piloté par le
logiciel pas vu pas pris alors là ce que
j'ai reçu il ya quelques jours une
courte vidéo envoyée sur mes réseaux
sociaux j'ai entrepris de vérifier
vérifier et encore vérifier cette
information
ventre à terre je suis allé sur un
célèbre moteur de recherche que vous
connaissez tous où je n'ai presque rien
trouvé dans le fil d'actu alors j'ai
recoupé les boudins faut je suis allé
fouiller et j'ai effectivement trouver
les vidéos originales de ses conférences
de presse notamment sur youtube j'ai
juste fait mon boulot de journalistes
tout comme d'ailleurs la rédaction de la
défense qui a publié un très bon article
à ce sujet sur leur site et au vu de la
teneur des propos tenus par ces quelques
députés européens je n'en reviens
toujours pas ce matin de la rachitique
couverture de presse pour cet épisode
suffisamment important dans l'histoire
du parlement européen ces conférences de
presse semble n'avoir jamais existé pour
de nombreux médias cela même même qu'ils
considèrent union européenne comme la
madonnina démocratique à laquelle ils
font dévotion matin midi et soir mais
heureusement que vous avez une réalité
parallèle danse bande de contraintes de
pas sanitaires et de qr code ce sont
quoi ce sont les réseaux sociaux car
sous le manteau numérique des réseaux
sociaux ces vidéos sont devenue virale
ayant dépassé le million de vues ces
dernières heures sans aucun appui
médiatique alors il se pose une nouvelle
fois la question fondamentale du code de
la presse et de cette façon de ne pas
trop insister sur la mascarade
démocratique de ce joyeux enclos
cadenassé qu'est l'union européenne
alors comment expliquez-vous nicholas ce
silence médiatique
ben je l'expliquais en fait par le fait
que les sujets abordés par ces
eurodéputés sont explosifs et je cite
aux pressions des peuples qui
manifestent contre la politique
sanitaire dans plusieurs pays européens
extorsion et manipulations du
consentement concernant la vaccination
de ces mêmes citoyens contrats opaques
entre l'union européenne et d'un
laboratoire pharmaceutique privée avec
une mise à l'écart des eurodéputés
remise en cause nos démocraties par les
élites européennes et brutalité avec
laquelle les restrictions sanitaires
sont imposés à tous et plus grave encore
plus grave la sincérité la parole d'état
sous couvert de faire le bien de sa
population pour des intérêts non à voir
ces deux eurodéputés franchement ils
vont très très très loin certains
certains se heurteront d'ivoire ou du
conspirationnisme et du complotisme mais
le conte petit charge amis dans cette
période très sombre nos démocraties
c'est de ne pas pareil ces conférences
de frais de ses eurodéputés car si le
compostage est une façon de se rassurer
sans devoir se fatiguer à réfléchir
loisirs et intellectuels de penser que
les citoyens sont trop stupides pour
comprendre année une manifestation
parfaite car le meilleur antidote
complotisme c'est d'avoir le courage de
porter ces juges dans le débat public
pour confronter débattre au lieu de
dissimuler des l'idée de dénigrer
d'accuser de vilipender de sanctionner
et comme le déclaré l'eurodéputé roumain
cristian intéresse je cite quand le
gouvernement s'est tout de vous c'est de
la tyrannie et je sais ce que c'est de
vivre dans la tyrannie mais quand on
s'est tous sur le gouvernement c'est la
démocratie fin de citation alors le plus
précieux consentement libre et éclairé
qui nous incombe c'est celui de la
démocratie et des droits de l'homme
merci beaucoup nicolas pour cet édito
nicolas vidal on retrouve tous les
jeudis matin dans la matinale et bien
sûr sur les réseaux sociaux et à
retrouver évidemment l'article d'arreter
france sur notre site arte france pointe
et v2